[Music]
now you've been to
okinawa quite a number of times
and i've spent a little bit of time
there okinawa is considered a blue zone
right they have a uh in certain portions
of okinawa
uh population
that contains i guess the
let's just call the per capita highest
percentage of centenarians or something
along those lines
what are some of the
lessons you've taken away from that or
observations that you've made
well it's such a different
world there you know they live in a
pacific paradise with clean water and
air they have an unbelievably varied
fascinating diet very different from the
japanese
diet
they get physical activity but one of
the things that most struck me
was the different attitude toward aging
in that society that old people are
valued as
national treasures efforts are made to
include them in all aspects of
of uh social life very different from
what you see here you know where we like
to isolate old people with other old
people and not have to deal with them
one of the stories i collected over
there
is that a common cause of sibling
fighting in traditional okinawan society
is over who is going to get to take care
of the aging parents that's a little a
little different from what we see here
so i think that's extremely important i
took my my mother there when she was i
think 90
89 or 90 i was invited to give a talk
at a conference in okinawa and uh
they like to trot out their centenarians
at all events so there was a bunch of
them at an opening party and they would
all come up to my mother and say i'm 101
how old are you and she was very
embarrassed about her her age and i
think it was it was interesting to watch
her be in a culture where people were
proud of being old
so that's one of the lessons i learned
i spent
a bit of time i want to say
four or five days in this village called
the origimi yes i know okay
yes
sort of the creme de la creme of the yes
of the centenarian olympics and
every person i met who seemed to be
saying their 90s or 80s 90s or beyond i
would ask what's the secret and i got
back a different answer from just about
everybody i'm sure there were a few
things that closely line up with what
you're saying one was
old people were active i mean people
were out in the gardens people were
members of coral societies we had a
driver at the time for a couple of days
and he would say well i'm still young
i'm still a young whippersnapper
basically and he was in his mid-80s
and we drove by a number of places where
he would point out he'd say that's where
the old people just sit inside watching
television that's the end
he's like that's when it's over and
it really seemed to be as you mentioned
the inclusive
nature of senior living in that area and
also the fact that they're
very engaged with community and very
very active i remember going to market
where they have the the purple tarot
which i'm sure yeah yeah you've seen
yeah and as you mentioned the diet is
very i mean it's becoming more
japanesized but it's very different from
what we typically think of
as japanese food but i have to tell you
tim that in the over the period of time
that i was going to okinawa okinawan
longevity has plummeted especially among
men yeah and that's been attributed
entirely to the increasing consumption
of american fast food and i remember uh
there was an article in new york times
about that and they quoted a middle-aged
okanagan man who said the first time he
tasted a mcdonald's hamburger he thought
he had died and gone to heaven i mean
how could that how could that be i mean
these people have the most wonderful
food available but there you go in just
such a short space of time you can see
the effects of that
you